Speaker 1: We had the 20th anniversary of 9/11
over the weekend and there is so much that can
be said. And yet how much is there that is new
that can be said about 9/11 that we've not said
on prior anniversaries? For me, one of the most
important things was the stark contrast over the
20 years between the twenty twenty one Republican
Party and the 2001 Republican Party. And
how out of place then President George W.
Bush looks within the modern Republican Party.
Speaker 2: Now what? Whoa, whoa.
Speaker 1: Am I rewriting history and
rehabilitating the image of George W. Bush?
No, that's not what I'm doing. Am I saying
George W. Bush's foreign policy decisions
back in 2001 and 2003 made any sense? No.
No, I'm not doing that, but what I am pointing
out is as much of a disaster as was George W.
Bush on foreign policy and in so many other ways.
The Republican Party today under the Magga brand
has become something orders of magnitude more
insane. And so what I'm going to play for you here
is a little bit of a speech that George W. Bush
gave on Saturday on the anniversary of 9/11,
in which he did something that I think is really
accurate, actually. He likened the Trump rioters
of January 6th to the 9/11 terrorists of 9/11
2001 and pointed out it's not just from abroad
that these threats can come, but even from
inside as well. Now, I want to again say
in this speech, George W. Bush says a ton of
nonsense. I don't like Bush. I don't think he
was a good president. I didn't vote for Bush.
You know, all these different things. Even in
this speech, Bush still acts like his military
actions in Afghanistan and Iraq made sense.
I don't agree with that. But he correctly draws
a line between the Trump rioters and the 9/11
terrorists and saying it's all people who wish
harm or want to do harm to the United States.
Let's take a listen to George W. Bush on Saturday.
Speaker 2: As a nation, our adjustments have been
around. Many Americans struggle to understand
why an enemy would hate us with such zeal.
The security measures incorporated into
our lives are most sources of comfort
and reminders of our vulnerability.
Speaker 1: But there is an example.
The security measures are also something that
many of us are concerned are sacrificing privacy
without really providing security. Like that's
a huge part of security measures. So so there's
still a ton of neocon propaganda here, but he
eventually gets to something very important.
Speaker 2: And we have seen growing evidence
that the dangers to our country can come not
only across borders, right. But from
violence that gathers within right,
there is little cultural overlap between violent
extremists abroad and violent extremists at home.
But then there's just danger terrorism in
their disregard for human life and their
determination to defile national symbols.
They are children of the same foul spirit,
and it is our continuing duty to confront them.
Speaker 1: He is absolutely right. I saw a great
comment on Reddit, which said in an attempt to
be the most conservative member of their party,
they're becoming so reactionary that they're
starting to reject basic aspects of human
civilization, like empathy for others that
can't directly help you. And that is exactly
the type of thing that George W. Bush is
pointing to now. Again, because I know,
you know, the Glenn Greenwald types are very
quick to say, look at all these soft leftists
lionizing Bush and forgetting, no, no, no, no,
no. Even in this speech, Bush acts like his
military actions in Iraq and Afghanistan made
sense after Trump, though, Bush comparatively
sounds relatively empathetic, comparatively
wise. And we have to still remember all the
bad. We're not rehabbing George W. Bush, but it is
a stark contrast here between what the Republican
Party was in 2001, which was already horrible.
It was horrible in 2001 to what it is today.
I get the sense that Bush as a person feels much
more comfortable and safe around the Obamas than
the trumpets. And this is also a reminder that the
Obama Democratic Party is not the the super left
socialist thing that the right believes it to be.
That's an important reminder here as well. Now,
the problem is when you try to talk about this
stuff, everybody wants black and white. David,
do you think Bush is great or do you think he's
terrible? Well, he was horrible on policy for
the times of 2001, 2003. He was a disgusting
reactionary, a terrible neocon. And he has
accurately identified the lunatic strath of the
Republican Party to Trump ism and has accurately
found an analogy between the Trump rioters
and the 9/11 terrorists. That's it. You know,
people want oh, if Bush gets along with Obama,
that means Obama is actually a right winger. No,
Obama is a center left Democrat. Bush is a is
a Republican. But compared to Magga cultists
who had every opportunity to do what is absolutely
worst for the country, they are closer to each
other in that way while still being significantly
different politically. And part of the problem is
it's not just the people on the right who
want to say, oh, Obama is a socialist Marxist,
Biden a socialist Marxist. There's also people on
the left who want to say if there's any agreement
between a Republican and a Democrat, it must
mean the Democrat is actually a right winger.
Let's try not to fall for these tired
tropes that are completely counterproductive
and actually discussing substantively the
issues facing the country. Bush was a disaster
and good for Bush, triggering the Magga people by
saying the January six people are more similar to
the 9/11 terrorist than you might think. Now,
one other thought on Twitter and Reddit, I saw
these right wing nuts saying when Bush referred
to the domestic people, he was talking about
Antifa and Black Lives Matter. No, he wasn't.
He obviously wasn't. There's no way in hell
that that's what George W. Bush was talking about.
Let's take a quick break. We'll have more on this
and the rest of today's stories on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.